hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es einen richtig leckeren
Nudelsalat
[Musik]
einige nudelsalatrezepte findet ihr
bereits auf meinem Kanal und ich finde
gerade im Sommer liebe ich Nudelsalat es
gibt ja Nudelsalat mit Mayonnaise es
gibt mediterran es gibt alle möglichen
und einer ist mit eingefallen und zwar
wird es jetzt eine Kombination aus
Nudeln und Papa zwiebelsalat und das war
so eine Eingebung ich hoffe es schmeckt
halt also rote Zwiebeln kommen mit rein
Nektarinen mit rein
es wird schon schmecken ich hoffe es
zumindest das hier sind die Zutaten ich
habe hier schon mal 250 Gramm Nudeln
abgekocht und einfach hier schon mal in
eine große Schüssel gegeben ich habe
auch kein Öl mehr dazu also die kleben
jetzt einfach nicht falls doch bewahrt
euch einfach ein bisschen Nudelwasser
auf hier habe ich ein paar Cashewkerne
bereits geröstet Petersilie etwas
Zitronensaft zum Abschmecken so mag das
ist ein essigbaumgewürz ist optional
dürft ihr gerne neben Minister habt hier
habe ich Nektarinen und zwei rote
Zwiebeln das war's Salz und Pfeffer
kommt noch dazu fertig
bekommt ihr übrigens im türkischen
Lebensmittel da könnt ihr gerne mal
schauen das ist richtig lecker es passt
zu Fleischgerichten Kartoffeln
zwiebelsalat und hoffentlich jetzt sagst
du Nudelsalat werden wir sehen was wir
auch sehr lieben mit zu Mark ist einfach
Äpfel schneiden in Spalten
Zitronensaft drauf bisschen Salz
bisschen Pfeffer das Leben die Kinder
also Zwiebel in feine Halbringe
[Musik]
dann den Nektarine die würde ich jetzt
einfach in Spalten schneiden ihr könnt
sie natürlich auch Würfeln aber so finde
ich es ein bisschen dekorativer
jetzt die Zitrone ein bisschen und dann
den Saft dazugeben und die Cashewkerne
die einfach groben ich finde es immer
ganz schön wenn man auch so ein bisschen
Crunch mit dabei hat in so einem Salat
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt hier so mag dazu Salz
Pfeffer Olivenöl das war's
und zum Nudelsalat dazu gibt es noch
einen Grill und pfannenkäse darf ich
jetzt hier den Gasi drin im pfannkäse
mit honey Barbie gut Geschmack den
gibt's auch mit Kräuter Natur oder auch
Chili aber den bereite ich dann gleich
zu erstmal kurz die Nudelsalat und den
pfannenkäse könnt ihr entweder in der
Pfanne zubereiten mit oder ohne Fett
oder eben auch ganz praktisch auf dem
Grill
der Nudelsalat ist fertig den pfannkäse
habe ich jetzt hier auch schon
angebraten von beiden Seiten richtig
lecker und jetzt kommt Alex zum
profilieren hallo oh das sieht ja
richtig lecker aus
also ich bin Nudelsalat Fan ja ich hoffe
du wirst
ich bin gespannt
aber es sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal
sehr gut aus ich habe mich inspirieren
lassen von Papas zwiebelsalat der macht
den Moment Petersilie zu Mark also es
ist ungewürz aber ich habe gedacht da
kommt noch was fruchtiges rein und der
Käse passt super dazu
Alex Programm schön und teile uns mit
dir schmeckt danke schön nachdem
also möchte erstmal Nudelsalat ich
probiere gleich mit
bis dahin
sehr gut
boah das ist unser Essen heute
richtig lecker
hast bestanden
doch recht gut falls Sie jetzt auch
Appetit bekommen habt findet ihr das
Rezept wie immer in meiner App da findet
ihr auch noch weitere Nudelrezepte bzw
nudelsalatrezepte und auch weitere
Rezepte mit dem Grillkäse da könnt ihr
mal schauen denn ich habe schon einige
Rezepte mit Grillkäse zubereitet denn
das ist für mich nicht einfach nur so
eine Beilage sondern wirklich so ein
schon so ein main character in so einem
Rezept ja macht schon viel her also
probiert es gerne aus ich freue mich auf
euer Feedback und bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
gute Frage wir können doch einfach noch
einen zweiten Teller voll hauen okay
[Musik]